hi guys sci-fi recap here before we
start
warning spoilers ahead so today
i'm going to explain a mind-blowing
science fiction movie from thailand
called deep
the movie starts by showing a man with a
medical suit who is trying to jump from
the top of the school building
scene continues to classroom where
professor nisha teacher and also
principal of the school
explain about insomnia she tells her
students that insomnia is a physical
disorder caused by stress and anxieties
and will bring worse effects if you keep
staying awake for longer time
such as perception of reality becomes
distorted hallucination
etc this is jane
and she is the main character in the
movie she is used to going without sleep
the medical student spends her night
studying caring for her grandmother
and worrying about her little sister
june she's obsessively concerned with
the safety of her house and checking the
lock multiple times only to make the
nights longer
this is june jane's sister june usually
comes home late because of practicing
music and her sister accuses her for
sleeping around
jun is unhappy with that statement and
they start fighting jun's phone falls
off and the screen is broken
june then walks away and leaves her
sister alone
when jane discovers that they are
extremely behind on their home loan
she comes to the school principal and
tells her that she wants to drop out
otherwise professor nicholas suggests
jane to sign up for a german
pharmaceutical project offering huge
cash compensation
the project is called deep which is
dedicated to harvest a chemical from a
brain called crotona that essentially
can be used to wake up coma patients
the project itself consists of three
levels and the duration of each level
varies from each person
the higher the level the more krashenin
that will be extracted
out of nowhere suddenly a man called dr
hans miller approaches jane
he is the director of research in the
company he offers jane to participate in
level one and she will be awarded three
thousand dollars upon completion
what jane really needs to do is implant
a microchip in the occipital area and
stay awake until a certain amount of
cretonin is extracted from her
because jane is so desperate to help her
family she finally agrees to the offer
hans also handed a watch to measure the
amount of crotonin harvested and to
alert the user if he or she falls asleep
if the user falls asleep for more than
60 seconds they will die
because of short circuit which will stop
the heart jane soon discovers three more
of her classmates are also part of the
experiment
it's win a top-class party animal who
spends more time in the club than
classroom
there's also sin famous beauty blogger
and peach
a gaming nerd who always follows sin
wherever she goes
the students become quite the foursome
and support each other through in order
to get easy money from the deep project
they finally got 100 in their watch
which indicates that their first level
has been completed and get the chip
extracted from their body
easy money given from the professor and
they immediately spend their money on
entertainment and stuff
jane gives her sister a brand new phone
and sin decides to spend the money for a
boob job
you know what i mean while playing
bowling
sin tells her friends that she has been
followed and stalked by someone lightly
and suspects that it's from the german
company
suddenly jane changed the topic and
asked her friend whether they want to
participate in the next level of deep
project
and all of them spontaneously says yes
because of the easy money the day after
they gather again at german companies
lab and ready for deep level two
this time they'll be required to produce
more krotonin so it will be about five
days with no sleep at all
they hesitate a bit at first but when
they find out that they will be paid
fifteen thousand dollars
they suddenly accept the offer after
three days without sleep
the indicator from the watch shows only
forty percent of crotonin has been
harvested
on the other hand they begin to feel the
side effects of staying awake
wind starts to hear strange things
hallucinating and suddenly punches his
friend for no reason while playing
basketball
jane also becomes emotionally unstable
and easily irritated
june asks her sister what happened and
how she could be able to gather that
huge amount of money
unhappy with the questions they get into
conflict and jane walks out from her
room
at this moment june spots the german
pharmaceutical business card and figures
out what jane has been doing
the next day the insomniac group meet at
the canteen and complain that the
crotonin percentages keep stucking low
at this moment
jane spots that win has a higher cortona
percentage than the rest of the group
and realizes that keep moving will
increase the percentage faster
they decide to conduct a night party at
peach's house
they are having fun and win figures out
a brilliant idea to keep them awake
which is mixing stimulant pills with
mocktails
at first jane hesitates to drink because
the pills may cause strokes
wind assures them that they need to make
it through the night and finally the
rest of the group drink the mixture
they continue to dance and surprisingly
jane starts to dance like a madman in
front of her friends
at this moment the kratonin percentage
rises sharply and wynn has already
harvested 83
after getting out from the toilet sin
accidentally goes into peach's room and
figures out that peach is the one who
has been stalking her all the time
sin is very shocked and suddenly faints
the situation turns into chaos
they need to wake her up while the time
in the watch keeps ticking
luckily because all of them are medical
students they manage to wake win up in
the last seconds and at this point
they finally managed to harvest one
hundred percent crotonin the next day
they come back to the company and state
that they will not proceed to level
three
the doctor keeps persuading them to
continue because nobody's done it better
than them
the doctor also offers enormous amounts
of money which is thirty thousand
dollars to the kids
but a no is a no they reject the offer
and walk out from the room
life goes on as they decide not to go
back to deep
since that stressful moment sin is not
willing to talk to peach again
even though peach confesses that he
likes sin and all of the stalking
happens because he cares about her
then we jump to a scene where wynn asks
jane to come with him to the ed sheeran
concert
but jane rejects the offer and says that
she has no time for doing such a thing
like that
jane then continues to walk home when
she suddenly sees a corpse wearing deep
projects watch on his wrist with zero
seconds on the screen
in the middle of the night jane's
grandma suddenly suffers stroke and has
to be taken to the icu
jane meets june and says that they
couldn't afford the hospital fee and
have to move their grandma into another
hospital
unexpectedly june pulls out a brown
paper bag and asks whether that amount
of money would cover the fee
jane figures out that june has also been
participating in deep project and is
very angry about it
and once again they have a fight in june
states that she also wants to help
grandma
filled by anger jane desperately comes
back to the company only to find out
that her sister has just implanted a
microchip to her body by dr hans miller
jane asked the doctor to remove the chip
off or she will call the police
but the doctor threatens jane back by
not going to take off the chip if jane
and her friend won't proceed to level
three
she takes her sister and walks away from
the lab she meets her insomniac friends
and begs for help
but majority of the group except win
refuse to participate in deep level 3
because it's a suicide and then leave
them
before sleep sin and peach flashbacks
their memories when they were having fun
with each other
and feeling guilty about it the next day
jane with her sister and win go back to
the lab and find that peach is already
waiting for them
surprisingly sin also comes and the
group continue to meet dr miller for
deep level three
to help the group get through the final
phase of deep project professor nichi
gives eggs are all every day to keep
them awake and provide an old lab for
them to stay
the principal also says that they can
call her anytime if they need help
each day goes fine until they reach day
six of the experiment where the group
start hallucinating again
suddenly sin screams in the toilet
breaks glass and scratches his face with
glass
sin goes into madness and blames jane
and her sister that her face looks like
[ __ ] because of them the atmosphere
starts to heat up and they begin to
fight one another
win attacks peach and says that one
wants to be friends with a sick loser
like him and because of that
win got a punch in his face given the
current condition
jane starts to panic and runs to find
the principal
jane finds a room and when entering the
room jane is very shocked finding out
that all this time they have been
monitored by the professor
jane also figures out that dr hans
miller is just a role and not an actual
doctor
jane returns to her friends and commands
his friends to call the police
immediately because
professor nisha is the mastermind of
deep project but they can't reach the
signal and when they are trying to
escape
they have been locked from outside the
principal calls from the intercom and
says that she will extract the chip
after 100 percent crotonin harvested or
after they died
finally they have reached day seven
aware of being watched
sin destroys all the cctv and when
suddenly faints
realizing that one of the students is
unconscious professor nichter comes to
the room and manages to bring wind to
his room
suddenly someone hits the professor from
behind and she falls down
unexpectedly it is win who comes back
from death the group gathers in the
professor room and explains that they
used ccl that could cause cardiac arrest
and fake a death
professor nichia explains that the man
that jumped at the beginning of the
movie was jed
her lover 24 years ago jed was able to
survive
but in order to escape from the coma jed
needs to be injected with certain
amounts of crotonin
that's why professor nitschke initiated
the deep project in order to extract
crotonin from sleep deprived human brain
feeling cornered professor nisha manages
to grab a syringe and injects drug into
jane and she suddenly collapses
when sin and peach try to hold the
principle back win and june try to wake
jane up
time has already passed 60 seconds but
jane still does not show any response at
all
this left them in a state of hopeless
despair when june's crying and hits his
sister's chest
it suddenly wakes jane up after that
professor nichia is arrested and none of
them getting paid for joining level
three
at the end everyone has chosen to sleep
like a rock rather than to sleep like
the dad and never to wake up and see the
sun again
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out
thank you for watching